the worst train crash Greece has ever
seen a passenger train colliding head-on
with a freight train
many of the 350 passengers were students
returning to Thessaloniki after a long
weekends celebrating Greek Orthodox Lent
many were killed in the initial impact
shortly before midnight others burnt in
a fire so hot it melted metal
those who made it out were still trying
to understand what happened
I jumped on him then we fell down a
woman with her child was with us the
train caught fire next to us and this
guy found a hole so we all managed to
get out
the whole train had bent 90 degrees and
had fallen over the cliff half of it was
hanging in the air and the whole thing
was on fire
there were five wounded where I was
prime minister
Mr Smith was ever seen if
he is
we are talking about an unspeakable
tragedy our thoughts today are first and
foremost with the relatives of the
victims our duty is to treat the wounded
and from there to identify the bodies
from there one thing I can guarantee we
will find out the causes of this tragedy
and do everything in our power to make
sure it never happens again
dozens of people stood in line to donate
blood at the hospital in the central
town of Larissa an angry families are
demanding answers
[Music]
we want all those responsible to pay for
this mess this Greek mess trains
derailing in 2023 is insane and on a
double track even from what we hear they
went from a double to a single track and
crashed
a station master has been arrested as
investigators try to establish how two
trains came to be on the same track
Uncle Sam Sharif Al Jazeera
now John sarapoulos is joining us live
from the scene of the crash and we're
here on John the Greek Prime Minister
has now said that the accident was
caused by tragic human error what more
can you tell us
that would seem to be a reference
Elizabeth to a purported confession by
the Larissa station master who was being
deposed today by the city prosecutor
apparently the man said that he
attempted to switch the passenger train
to the second track as it left the
station but that it didn't for some
reason respond the switches didn't work
and he still let the train go on its way
without telling on anybody else about
the problem well if that is true if that
confession is accurate then that is very
much the immediate problem that led to
the Collision of these two trains
evidently the station Master didn't have
any idea that a freight train was
heading down the track in the opposite
direction which then raises questions
about how well station Masters
communicate across the Greek passenger
Network which is also a great Network
the um
problem however is wider as we heard
from one of the witnesses earlier in
that report it is
uh simply faced with incredulity here
that two trains should Collide in a
double track section of the Athens to
Thessaloniki Railway Network and this is
something that the government has been
trying to establish double tracks
throughout the railway Network precisely
in order to avoid such collisions so the
problem is also why uh automatic
signaling hasn't been put in place that
would have provided another safety layer
of safety to warn human operators about
oncoming trains or about trains that are
on a Collision Course and there are
still questions to be answered about the
sections of the track which remain
single and what regime prevails there
when a freight train and a passenger
train want to use those sections of
track I think there's going to be a lot
of questions asked in the coming days
and weeks about how Greek rail is
organized and they affect not only the
operations but also the infrastructure
and John just how have people in Greece
been
reacting you know to this incident given
just how unusual it is for such such a
high number of death from such transport
incidents in the country
well there's been an outpouring of
Sympathy for the victims and for their
relatives long queues of people have
have been formed here in the city of
Larissa to give blood to the hospital
typically blood is requested by the
National Health System whenever there's
a disaster lots of surgeries to be done
and there's also a lot of a lot of
verbal sympathy we've heard expressed
from people on the street on our way up
here but there's bound also to be
outrage over the fact that this thing
could happen in 2023 after so many
hundreds of millions of Euros have been
poured in government money and European
Union money into improving the Greek
rail network
John thank you very much for that that
is John ceropoulos with the latest uh
live near Larissa thank you